hey what's up guys my name is eternal
welcome to episode 18 of game
programming so yesterday we took a look
at actually implementing the key handler
class or the keyboard class which
actually uh we were able to print out
true when we press the UH power and a
false if it was released if it wasn't
pressed so I'm today we're just going to
take a look at actually I guess putting
this to use so now obviously we've got a
way to actually um gather key inputs and
we can record them but how do we
actually use this to animate our our
tile our map and what we'll do first is
actually get rid of this printing thing
so we are we don't want to do that one
thing that you can actually do is um
actually do this alright what you can do
is you can actually scan through every
single one so like keys dot length right
every single one of this keys and what
you can do is say if you know keys I I
it's true right then what you can
actually do is print system dot out dot
print line you can print the key that is
press and it's just like for fun so we
can see which one we print so if we just
type this real quick um and do this what
you'll get is Oh make sure you print on
the
if you actually just print I you'll
actually know what which key ID it is so
if we print if we go up you can see
there's key number 38 if we add if we
add W that's key 87 a is 65 D is 68 s is
83 down is 40 left is 37 39 38 so 37 38
39
so left up right down is that's rolling
but yeah that's just like a little fun
little thing that you can do to actually
find out the IDS of the case so in other
words how the stalls as you can see we
didn't actually get anything by just
open the console here we didn't actually
get anything higher than 87 so in other
words what I'm saying is 120 should
probably be fine now notice if we had
put this 285 and we try to think what's
the W key right well first of all a
crash straight away and the reason it
crashed was the up key the W key was
simply above that you can see it's the W
key here is 87 and we limited it to 85
so that's a little more in-depth
understanding on to why we put 120 here
it yeah we just want to wait we just
want to have enough enough variables
here and of boolean's in this array to
actually store abilene for every every
key on our keyboard okay now actually
applying this now is relatively simple
all right we go back into our game java
class we see that we actually have
access to the key class of course
through our little keyboard key
declaration here now what we can do
is we've currently got it moving through
this and to actually have it move when
we press the appropriate key we can
simply type if K dot up for our up key
equals true right if K dot up then let's
just 1 minus minus right because it
actually drag our map up and similarly
if I just get rid of this we can do the
same thing for all of our other little
control so key dot down will be y plus
plus K dot left will be M X minus minus
and K dot right will be X plus plus so
if we if we launch this you'll see I'm
that I'm just pressing the arrow keys
now and you can see that our map is
indeed moving now it looks like it's
actually I think I can see it on my
computer is lagging like crazy there
were 2000 FPS because of my screen
recorder so if this turns out lagging up
if this turns out laggy for you guys on
the video that's that's the screen
reporters fault okay if you do it
yourselves on your computer you should
get no lag obviously we're at 2,000
frames per second here yeah you can see
that I'm a actually able to move myself
around the map to my pleasing um simply
by adding you know a few lines of code
so um so yeah and we can actually uh
could actually start to do something
with this now so yeah I hope you enjoyed
this episode of game programming guys if
you did please hit the like button and
also yes tomorrow where we'll move on
integrating our game actually one quick
thing I want to address a lot of people
seem to be asking if this game will be
multiplayer now I did mention that this
game will be like to realm of the mad
God and as you know a realm of Matt God
is multiplayer so yes this game the
we're making here rain will be
multiplayer ok the idea of the series is
to create realm of the mad God from
scratch simple as that I'm not even
gonna say a game like Rome on the map
God because what we're going to do it
first is basically create realm of the
mad God from scratch then from there and
then from there you know will obviously
modify it and and do whatever whatever
is we need to do but one thing that I
really wanted to stress real quick guys
is that
I really want to involve you guys in
this series so when we actually come to
designing things and actually you know
making core gameplay decisions
I'll definitely um get you guys into
this and make sure that you guys have a
have a say in what you get taught I
guess and what what this series really
becomes so um yeah anyway that's that's
episode which what upset with this is 18
yep
that's absurdity no game programming
guys hope you enjoyed if you did add it
to your favorites hit the like button
and I'll see you guys see you guys
tomorrow with a brand new episode later
guys
[Music]